creating those opportunities as well
ladies Virginia which affair just won
the national championship it's Harris's
NBA season
and this year played in 64 game that's a
career-high
a lot of action since the all-star break
we need no until about 7:00
[Applause]
what super downsizes Dudley's at the
fire
[Applause]
gets his own message
the minutes assent beat here it's 10
apiece in the first - Russell into the
paint flips it up at in his first two
point basket 15 point lead eight
straight for the next Butler
it's romantic
[Applause]
five for the floor three points and meat
is one of nine over five degree in
Brussels and he switches it up there's
bumbler on the drive goes white and
Geritol is got great sport by the Nets
here in the quarter
Russell with the pawn connects so he
goes to the middle is because Joelle is
back in sync
Russell in transition does he get picked
up
Jimmy Butler wet finishes
believe is back to eight it's now got 14
points on five for 17 nice pass by 12 on
to Jimmy Butler is up to 27 points
opportunity here
the Lakers back in 20
it's again we started up now and he's
just look at the patients he showed me
two of this series Monday here in Philly
[Music]
[Applause]
it's road win in the playoffs Russell is
bumped and he gets the bounce the end to
the Russell up to 18 points player and
the history the NBA to do that if you
are included in a sentence of change
[Applause]
five of seven from the floor they don't
get out of Ross so he pulls up
it's another one he's
the minutes before we came on the air
till about 2:23 Eastern Time there's a
typical physicality
near Santa Russell at 14 - the first
picks up blast-off